and 48 foreign countries can you believe
that 100 you talk about a spread you
talk about a a violent spread 148
countries not even believable there's
been a week of national action and of
great national solidarity people are
getting along we're getting along with
Republicans and Democrats and
independents and liberals and
conservatives and actually it's a very
nice thing to see we're all one
beautiful big American family and that's
taking place right now
last night I approved major disaster
declaration for the state of New York I
worked very closely with Governor Cuomo
and is the first time in our nation's
history that a presidents used the
Stafford act to declare a major disaster
in response to a public health crisis
never happened before I'm considering
other areas where we may or may not be
doing it and working very closely with
Gavin Newsom governor of California and
others we may be doing the same thing
depending on their needs
depending on what they are asking for
it's been unprecedented action in New
York and we've had a tremendous federal
response all over the country and I want
to thank all the people in the federal
government and obviously in the state
governments and local governments we are
working hard everybody is working hard
and the people standing alongside of me
are working very hard that I can tell
you we've also reached agreements with
Canada and Mexico on new travel rules at
our northern and southern borders to
halt the entry of the Chinese virus well
continuing trade and commerce and we've
had very good talks I've with Prime
Minister Trudeau and today this morning
with President Lopez Obrador we talked
about joint measures that were taking to
prevent the spread of the virus
our countries and to temporarily suspend
non-essential travel we had a great
conversation this morning president of
Mexico and our close cooperation with
Mexico and Canada will keep our people
healthy keep their people healthy keep
everybody safe
yesterday I had a call with 12,000 small
businesses representatives of these
businesses that's the engine of our
country people don't realize that you
know you read all about the big ones but
these small business when you add them
up together is a really the engine
economic engine of ARCA
you
all right welcome everybody we've got
something a little bit different for you
today today we have a Fox News virtual
town hall with President Donald Trump
and members of the coronavirus task
force at least as of a few minutes ago
the standard coronavirus task force
press briefing is not on Trump's
calendar today there's very little on
Trump's calendar interestingly enough
and this is essentially the only thing
on the calendar today and it's on there
twice let's take a look at it here's
Donald Trump's calendar for today and as
you can see the 12:30 president
participates in a Fox News virtual town
hall from the White House oh and also
there's an interview with Bill Hemmer on
Fox News happening after the virtual
Town Hall that's all that he has and by
the way that's considered a campaign
event campaign schedule the only
official schedule item for Trump today
is a virtual Town Hall with Fox News
adjust this light yesterday he had lunch
with pence and then did the gong show
press briefing that we all watched
together last night so we're standing by
for that he has the best calendar excuse
me and is doing is doing just amazingly
amazing at everything that he does all
the time
permanently um the big concern is that
Donald Trump oh and welcome to every
we're doing this just on YouTube and
twitch I just don't know about doing
that there's a risk to doing the Fox
News Town Hall anyway but Twitter and
Facebook I just wasn't sure about so
we're just doing YouTube and twitch
today if you have anything we have about
a half hour until this starts so if
anybody has any questions comments or
anything like that you can if you're
watching on YouTube send a super chat
it'll show up in the lower left where it
says no new super chats right now which
is these are the depressing early
moments of every stream when nobody has
said anything I will answer your
questions and address that remember to
hit like and subscribe as you enter if
you were watching on Twitch it's the
blue vertical box twitch has gone
vertical whereas YouTube has a
horizontal box box shape I know is a big
thing in a lot of online communities on
Twitch you can send a message with your
prime or regular subscription and it'll
show up in that vertical blue box up
there um so here's the thing that is
increasingly clear Donald Trump seems
like he is preparing to do what Anthony
foul she is calling let it rip let it
rip and Trump now saying he goes on
around 1:00 p.m. so we've got a little
bit of time to talk so Trump is
signaling that people are going back to
work
Trump talked about this morning he
tweeted our people want to return to
work they will practice social
distancing and all else and seniors can
be watched over protectively and
lovingly we can do two things together
the Cure cannot be worse by far than the
problem Congress must act now we will
come back strong this is happening at
the exact same time that states are
adding shelter in place stay at home
orders in Massachusetts now
non-essential businesses have been
directed to closed we are all working
from home we're completely shut down
this is extraordinarily dangerous and
Donald Trump is essentially saying we
are calculating that we are okay with
instead of 5,000 people dying or 10,000
people dying we're okay with 50 or a
hundred or however many thousand people
dying Trump signaled this last night let
me see if I can find it
Trump flew car accidents
I believe he signaled this last night
let's see if we can watch it together
here it is going to be watching our
senior citizens very closely we're gonna
be watching certain hotspots like New
York and within New York you have areas
which are troubling and we'll be working
with the governor and the mayor and
everybody else on those spots but at the
same time at a certain point we have to
get open and we have to be we have to
get moving we don't want to lose these
companies we don't want to lose these
workers we want to take care of our
workers so we'll be doing something I
think relatively quickly but we've
learned a lot during this period this
was a very necessary period tremendous
information was gained but we can do two
things at one time you know and again I
say we have
a very active flu season more active
than most it's looking like it's heading
to 50,000 or more deaths deaths not
cases 50,000 deaths which is that's a
lot and you look at automobile accidents
which are far greater than any numbers
we're talking about that doesn't mean
we're going to so this is obviously you
guys see what he's doing this is
obviously a signal that he wants to open
things back up now that there's a couple
different things number one the flu
death rate is significantly lower than
the death rate for coronavirus
coronavirus death rate is not 3.5% we
know that but even if it ends up being 1
percent or 0.75 percent even 0.75
percent is four to five times greater
than the flu that's number one number
two the flu doesn't overwhelm the
ventilator capacity and the ICU numbers
and start to make every hospital
procedure more risky in the sense that
when the system is pushed to the
capacitor that to the max outcomes
worsen and then the the car accident
thing is really done because the point
here is that coronavirus deaths and
cases are increasing exponentially right
we would be treating car accidents
differently if they looked like this
right if there was if the question was
do we do an intervention to stop this
car accidents are tragic but comparing
them to coronavirus is crazy I mean
again look at these numbers as you see
here daily new cases just accelerating
more and more and more in the United
States active cases accelerating deaths
accelerating and the idea that we're
talking about even you know even
remotely the same thing is it is crazy
quite frankly okay if you're just
joining us today we don't have the
standard press briefing today we have a
fox news town hall with donald trump
starting somewhere between you know 40
50 minutes from now we'll be here until
then answering your questions and and
reading your comments and and the entire
thing and also we will be looking at a
number
videos and things that I have available
for you we do as usual have a new member
goal of twenty five we've got a great
discount people have been really
supportive of the streams and and we so
very much appreciate it
let me look at some of the super chats
that are coming in Len a--the asks David
do you think doctor foul chew will be
present for this no idea that the
relationship between Trump and foul Chee
at this point is definitely problematic
and we don't we don't know what's going
on with with foul Chee Andrew Hodge says
nobody cares about audience questions
sorry oh I'm sorry to hear that we you
know we normally get you know several
hundred of them every hour that we
stream so it seems a folks something not
everybody agrees Andrew Joey Gomez says
I like the way you say the words
subscribe subscribe I don't know how
else to say it Marika says being bored
and streaming more we are doing a lot of
streaming these days Zachary Monroe says
hashtag support TDPS hashtag one of the
best of the independence thanks Zachary
Zachary is at almost every stream and
regularly participating tag are Ian says
called reps yesterday tried McConnell
voicemail full not surprising incredible
says going to be my last super shot for
a while since I'm being hit hard by this
sorry to hear that
how is Trump's approval this high right
now best which it wishes David it is it
is sick that trumps approval has gone up
during what to call it a Miss handling
implies that there's been a handling and
I don't even know that there has been
it's crazy what's going on Charlie says
new hotness Trump branded forsythia I
don't know what that is I don't know
that I'm not sure what that is it's a
genus of flowering plants in the Olive
family there are 11 species hi Maisie
Trejo says governor De Santis
will not shut down Florida yeah I've
been reading that Christopher hellström
says config to the flu Cove it causes
acute pneumonia right
yeah the the the the you have to listen
I think you guys all know that Trump's
comparison of this to the flu and to
driving cars it could not be more wrong
let me say thanks to toxic Joker who has
given away five subscriptions on Twitch
thank you
toxic Joker very much appreciate that
captain red has subscribed for the
second month in a row and says I have
been subscribed for two months love your
videos and streams thanks captain red
very much appreciate your support also
want to say thanks to Corte Neos kurta
Neos Corte Neos who has subscribed for
the first time for the first time on
Twitch very much appreciate that we now
have here's something else I wanted to
show you as we wait for the Fox News
townhall with Trump here is Sean Hannity
just suggesting a treatment a
prophylactic a cure for corona virus
while on the phone with Mike Pence this
is of course ludicrously irresponsible
take a listen mr. vice president I'm
holding up a letter and I'm gonna read
from it in a second from a doctor than
New York area and if I may read from it
he has now worked with his his
associates and he has a regimen Hydra
regimen regimen oxy chloroquine 200
milligrams twice a day five days as in
throw myosin 500 milligrams once a day
five days in sulfate 220 milligrams once
a day for five days this okay let's stop
there let's just let's do this I want to
do this piece by piece
okay so chloroquine with or without as a
throw Meissen yes it's part of a
clinical trial right now significant
side effects including for people who
should not be taking it these are
medications that have to be prescribed
by doctors so the even mentioning this
is hey here's something you can go and
take to protect you from coronavirus
very irresponsible and in fact there is
a fish tank cleaner that shares an
ingredient in common with chloroquine
it's obviously not medical chloroquine
guy in Arizona died and his wife is in
critical condition because he thought Oh
chloroquine I'll buy chloroquine
phosphate which is a fish tank cleaner
and I'm gonna drink it
he died his wife is in a critical
condition because they believed that
they were buying chloroquine the
medicine of course it's not that needs
to be given with a doctor's prescription
and only in certain situations guy died
yesterday okay
the azithromycin okay we've talked about
that zinc zinc we we know about zinc
already there are people there are there
are some who claim that zinc can be a
prophylactic for the common cold others
who say it's not we don't have a cure
for the common cold but there's the it's
asserted that zinc can be a prophylactic
for the common cold remember some common
colds are a corona virus some are I
believe a rhinovirus there's four
different types of viruses that
sometimes cause the common cold if
you're not zinc deficient in your diet
it's unclear you get anything from
having additional zinc okay so so far
this is the regimen that that Sean
Hannity is suggesting now listen to how
crazy it gets this is what he has seen
him and his team have now treated
approximately 350 patients and Kyra's
Joel was an area of New York that was
hit particularly hard and another
hundred and fifty patients okay let me
explain
Sean Hannity doesn't even know what he's
reading Kyra stroll it's curious Joelle
curious Joelle is an overwhelmingly
Orthodox Hasidic Jewish community about
an hour north of the city a lot of the
people that work at BH photo/video in
New York City live in curious Joel okay
we when when had it let's assume
Hannity's telling the truth as he knows
it
Orthodox Jews have a lot of kids this is
just a reality when he says 350 people
have taken this and nobody has died this
might have been given to 350 young
people in Kiryas Joel who didn't even
have coronavirus imagine that what is
being asserted is 350 young people who
were unlikely to have serious cases of
coronavirus anyway took this and they're
fine it's meaningless and we don't know
what
hell Sean Hannity's talking about in
other New York areas his results we have
had zero deaths zero hospitalizations
zero intubations mr. vice president so I
think you guys get it that that's
meaningless data if we if we're not
talking about you know a controlled
trial it's it's just creates truly crazy
what is happening on the on the Sean
Hannity program let me say thank you to
Kaldur Ashe for the bits maruko so de su
for the bits and small forest for the
bits very much appreciate that let me
also say thanks to Kevin Wallace kevin
is new member number one today at join
pakman.com and Jason ranch ow is new
member number two today at join
pakman.com Kevin and Jason thank you for
your support
really very much appreciate it let's see
a breezy breeze own breeze 3-1 says
thanks for the streams much more
tolerable to view through you than our
cable news channels stay healthy thank
you I appreciate I appreciate the
support this is a bee says lush refused
to close in Toronto claims essential I
don't know what lush is so I'm unable to
comment we did do a story today on our
bonus show which all of our members get
about there is now a debate over what
counts as a as an essential business in
California they've determined that
medical marijuana dispensaries are
considered essential businesses in other
states
that's literally illegal and people go
to prison so there's this patchwork of
laws and increasingly we're heading
towards a showdown between the federal
government and the states Donald Trump
is clearly telegraphing that he is
getting ready to open the floodgates and
say let's get back to work
old people be careful that's essentially
what Donald Trump is telegraphing he
wants to do on the other hand we have
states that are increasingly passing
stay-at-home orders and we I don't know
who is going to win that battle
we don't know what you only need to look
at this to understand what it is that
Donald Trump has in mind which is that
on the basis of the coronavirus rescue
bill getting closer and Donald Trump's
starting to allude to we're gonna open
it back up the market is now up 8.8%
today now of course I love to see that
in the sense that I am miserable by what
is happening to my investments but it
doesn't appear to be the right thing
right now let's by the way take a look
at some of the stocks I've bought
recently and see how they're doing
zoom is down 8% zooms been up huge
lately but it is down
what else did I buy I bought Roku how's
Roku doing Roku's up 12 another 12% okay
Roku has exploded over the last few days
glad I got in on that one last week I
did get bear on the notion that bear
might do well because they're one of the
chloroquine manufacturers it's up less
than the market today so that that may
not go anywhere and then Live Nation I
bought because it crashed because they
do live events
my thought was it'll eventually recover
and it did have a big crash as you can
see big crash but it has been recovering
so anyway who knows I'm just trying I
don't know what I'm doing right none of
this is financial advice I'm just I'm
trying to hedge in some some way shape
or form but I have no clue what on earth
I'm doing let me say thanks to Lucas the
great who has subscribed with twitch
prime this is a bee says because we sell
soap while Ontario is in a state of
emergency okay I you know I don't know
exactly the specifics of what's
happening in Canada Lisa brown has
grabbed a youtube soy boy level
membership thanks Lisa
Bryan Holaday says my parents support
Biden because of proximity to Obama and
Clintons are returned to normal politics
Bernie's policies seem unrealistic and
he has not reached out to the black
community enough to them I I'm hearing
that from a lot of a lot of folks
Aiden Dowden says hey David if we end up
loosening restrictions do you think a
general strike would be effective
potentially but is a general strike
likely in that scenario I don't know I
think a lot of people will be desperate
to get back to work and a lot of people
may risk it and not want to do a general
strike if you're just joining us on
Twitter remember to hit that follow
button very much appreciate that if you
are watching on YouTube make sure to
LIKE and subscribe hit that like button
and also hit that subscribe button both
very much appreciated as we stand by for
the Donald Trump a Fox News townhall
starting as far as we know at the top of
the hour thanks also to sudden echo for
subscribing with twitch prime very much
appreciate that okay let's take a look
while we have some time at the latest
case numbers we now are officially over
400,000 cases we now are at over 17,000
deaths and more than a hundred thousand
people have recovered from the virus so
far active cases of course increasing
dramatically there are now 260,000
people that we know of who currently
have corona virus if you look at closed
cases the numbers are ugly because 14%
of closed cases have ended in death but
remember only about a quarter of the
cases so far have had an outcome now the
global numbers still look very ugly very
very ugly there are some signs that
Italy may have turned a corner we don't
know they have been locked out locking
down for weeks at this point and what we
see there is that now we have an
additional day in a row with fewer new
cases in Italy that's a good sign it's
still early the deaths have also
declined for three you know we've had
three successive days since peaking I
guess it's really only two days with
declines and we are we are watching that
in Italy the numbers in Spain I believe
are not quite yet improving in the way
that we would like to see daily new
cases spiking dramatically yesterday and
deaths in Spain also spiking
dramatically yesterday Spain does seem
to be behind Italy so far we continue to
track an extremely low death rate in
Germany we don't yet know what the
explanation is for the low death rate in
Germany very very few deaths in Germany
understand that even though there was a
spike yesterday we're talking about 29
and overall in Germany you're looking at
a hundred and thirty three deaths over
31,000 cases there is there are a number
of hypotheses the all of the above could
be true younger people on average
getting it in Germany healthier people
on average getting it in Germany a
medical system that is not overwhelmed
which we know dramatically reduces the
death rate or it's still earlier in
Germany and thus the deaths who will be
following tragically closely behind the
new cases when you look at active cases
right now that we know about Italy with
the most but probably by tomorrow the
United States will have the most active
cases and of course these numbers
drastically understate we probably have
you know half a million - more than a
million active cases here in the United
States we really don't know could be 1.5
million we have no idea
followed by Spain Germany France Iran
and then everybody else is below 10,000
official cases Switzerland also is a
point of interest a smaller population
than a lot of other countries also
maintaining a very low death rate
compared to some other countries higher
than some others and we want to track
Switzerland to see if they're able to
turn the corner more quickly those are
some of the key places that are being
looked at via a lot of people say look
at Iran because Iran has a lot of cases
and a high death rate we don't even know
how accurate the data is if you look at
Iran it's a very steady number of new
cases any
and when you look at deaths also a very
steady number of deaths in Iran and
there's a number of commentaries that
say that the the Iran numbers are just
sort of hard to believe when you when
you consider them in total I don't know
I don't know well we'll have to see and
of course nobody knows the actual real
case number the official case number is
just just a tiny fraction of that okay
super chats continue to come in let's
see here Jamal Swift says thanks homie
Thank You Jamal Jamal has been uh in in
the live streams regularly great to see
you again
Adam Waddington says aren't press
conferences a big transmission risk yeah
we still don't know why it is that
everybody stands so close to each other
at these press conferences and social
distancing seems to be ignored by the
people at the actual press conferences
it seems to me that it's a bad idea we
learned yesterday and more data today
about a White House reporter who has
been in those press conferences who now
has the virus and is not has further
culled the number of people in the in
the White House press briefing room
jf gambie has grabbed a youtube
subscription at the SOI boy level thank
you very much and I will remind folks we
do have a goal of 25 new members today
at join pakman.com we are to every time
someone signs up this blue bar starts to
fill up and it eventually explodes off
the side of the screen you can use the
coupon code listed up there
20:20 now to save 66% off of your
membership the other thing i want to
mention we have stay at home orders in
about 20 states so far if you're bored
if you're looking for something to do we
are doing something we are we have a
community event tomorrow night tomorrow
night March 25th 8 p.m. eastern time 5
p.m. Pacific here in the US we will be
having the David Pakman show viewer
chess tournament the first annual now
right now I am the champion of the David
Pakman show chess
thing I guess there's only been one game
so far I defeated Pat on one of our last
shows of 2019 so I am the 2019 David
Pakman show chess champion my record is
one an O over Pat who never plays all
right so it's not super impressive this
trophy will go to someone else
almost certainly there's people rated
over 2,000 in our audience tomorrow
night this is open to anyone
my goal is we have at least 50 players I
hope we have way more the tournament
will be on Leach s org that's Li chess
dot org make an account there I will
start streaming tomorrow night about 15
minutes before the tournament I will
tweet out the link to the tournament we
will probably set up a redirect at david
pakman.com slash chess which will take
you to the tournament open to everyone
the system will automatically match you
with people of your skill level as you
win you play against better people if
you lose you'll get matched up against
people who aren't quite as good the
system uses data it'll take care of
everything it's gonna be beautiful and
we will get a trophy for the David
Pakman show chess tournament to the
winner tomorrow night I would be shocked
if it's me because I'm not that good and
we've got a lot of really good really
good players but everybody should play
ok so that that's tomorrow night this is
free okay
this cost nothing I wanted I'm not
selling anything just it's an
opportunity to do something if you've if
you've been bored if you're looking for
something to do tomorrow night okay
let's see here um M says I've been
injecting emergency for three weeks very
promising yeah I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't do that if I were you
Justin Valcourt has grabbed a soy boy
level membership on YouTube brain Stu
says chili no ID revolución seen
canciones sing with me
there's no revolution without songs okay
Norwegian trad Archer is a soy boy now
Casey mcc's tix has grabbed a soy boy
level membership Charlie says can non
chess players hang out and watch or
it really just for players yeah you so
I'm going during the chess tournament
tomorrow night I'll be doing a live
stream so instead instead of seeing the
Fox News Town Hall you will see my chess
board and the leaderboard I'll I will
stream the entire tournament so if you
don't want to play you just want to
watch I'll be streaming tomorrow night
okay more EP asks David you are awesome
are you single I love data mails I'm not
single but also I'm heterosexual and I
think Maury I think is more ease only a
man's name right I think I don't know
so I exclude lis date women that's just
a thing that I do you know I I say I was
born that way I know that there's a lot
of homophobes that say you choose sexual
orientation but my belief is I was born
that way and I can't I can't change who
I am guys I'm sorry let me say thanks to
Ashlyn for subscribing with to on twitch
at Tier one let me say thank you to
Raghu 1992 for subscribing with twitch
prime also thanks to Corte Neos for
cheering I very much very much
appreciate that thank you so much folks
wondering what's going on so today it
appears as though there is not a
standard Trump coronavirus press
briefing when we looked at Donald
Trump's schedule for the day let's
refresh it to see if it's been updated
all that Trump has on his schedule today
is the Town Hall scheduled for 12:30 and
then an interview also on Fox News at 3
p n3 m otherwise Trump's schedule is
clear so golf simulator tweeting you
know watching Fox News I guess whatever
else and he has had a very light
schedule most days yesterday all he had
was lunch with Mike Pence and then that
gong show press briefing day before all
he had was the press briefing day before
he had a couple he had one phone call
and a press briefing so Trump is keeping
a very very light schedule and today all
that is on the schedule is a Fox News
townhall Trump scheduled to come out in
about 20 minutes or so so that's where
that
what we're waiting on at this point in
time let me say thanks to Jacob
shneidman Jacob shneidman Mazel Tov on
the new membership number three at join
pakman.com appreciate it very very much
Jacob okay let's see here essential says
have you been watching the Senate live
you know I've been in production all
morning and then now I'm streaming so
I've not been watching the Senate today
Richard Harris says I recently became a
member at join pakman.com how does this
differ from a YouTube membership am I
missing any incentives no the most
incentives the perks really are at join
pakman.com all of the other ways to sign
up patreon or petraea as I've heard some
people say it people I don't associate
with but I have heard that posited very
strongly patreon YouTube subscriptions
all that stuff we lose a bigger slice
then on our website at join pakman.com
so the best place to sign off to sign on
to sign up I think is what I'm still
trying to say is join pakman.com where
we we keep everything but a 2.9% little
tiny slice of your payment Alex Jones
says can you a man or not doing it Alex
Jones has been spending a lot of money
the last few days trying to get me to
just read insults about my friend
Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell the
second and I just I'm just not doing it
I hope that these are good investments
for you Alex but I'm not I'm not going
to do it more EP says I'm heterosexual -
but exceptions can be made ok Wow
more eve getting very very excited there
about a lot of a lot of different things
going on let's just listen real quick to
what's being said on Fox News just to
get a sense of it thank you both every
morning when I wake up I go to the Johns
Hopkins global map and I'm studying data
and numbers from various countries not
just ours with South Seoul and China and
Italy in Spain over the weekend - does
anyone believe Bill Hemmer studying data
data that you look for the moment you
wake up in the morning well it really is
how we begin every me
the white house coronavirus task force
dr. deborah birx is probably the leading
expert on infectious disease in the
world notice by the way how Burks has
fallen in line now but Fowey has not so
now all of a sudden it's not foul she
who's the authority it's deborah birx
it's it's amazing how they have uh
everything is crafted everything is
crafted jinxed carrie has grabbed a
twitch Prime subscription with the
message League of Legends for nerds
I've never played League of Legends I
have no clue what it is is it is it like
a Warcraft type game I have no clue what
we are talking about when we talk about
League of Legends let me say thanks to
Jay woz Jay was his new member number
for today join pakman.com Jay woz
thank you for your support very much
appreciated we should just be about 15
20 minutes from the spark start of this
Donald Trump Fox News Town Hall near the
top of the hour
fried rice official says David when's
the only fans starting excited for it I
don't know what only fans is I have no
clue what that means only fans see what
that means social media service based in
London creators run paid subscription
content with ways to build out
relationships yeah I have no clue I've
never heard of that before
Ben Taylor says hey David hope you're
well do you know if there is a David
Pakman fan club official or unofficial I
haven't it's certainly not an official
one I think the fan club is just called
you sign up at join pakman.com Alex
Jones says David best investment ever
okay Alex Jones I think has now spent
about 50 bucks over the last few days
just insulting Stephen Kenneth Destiny's
bonel the second via super chat and
claims it's a good investment
Leonardo M says what's your take on
whether or not Trump supporters will
change their stance on his crisis
management and if it will affect poll
numbers or election
I don't even pretend to have a
prediction on that because as Donald
Trump has bungled the response to the
virus
his approval rating has gone up and more
than half the country approves of how
he's been handling this so it's clearly
I don't have the right lens through
which to analyze this because Donald
Trump's response has been horrifying so
I can't I can't tell you what's gonna
happen
Lance Powers says what do you make of
Michael Levitt a Nobel laureate and
Stanford biophysicist saying deaths are
actually going to slow down this week I
hope that he is right I hope that he is
right and I actually read
hold on yzma is that the Israeli guy yes
it is yes listen his area of expertise
is not infection right he works in a
completely disable Laureate it's like oh
it's a doctor I I hope he's right I mean
listen anybody who makes an optimistic
prediction I hope they're right even if
they're unqualified to make it in the
sense that I'm I am always hoping for an
improvement but I don't know that he is
he's the right guy for it
Jay Harper says only fans is Twitter for
porn
that's basically it okay hot mustard gas
says only fans as an adult site oh all
right
fried rice official says please unban me
from your twitch at Pepe hands I'm not
involved in any of that I I'm not
involved in that I've opted out of that
sazar marin says I was gay-bashed in
March in 2019 in Phoenix and now Asian
Americans are being targeted Trump needs
to go he's to blame I I I'm not in a
position to to comment specifically on
that but I've said before that Donald
Trump has coalesced and catalyzed a lot
of hate a lot a lot of hate let me say
thank you to oh let me see if I can
pronounce this correctly
Jesse pockets in ski Jesse pagas in ski
is new member number five at join
pakman.com thanks Jesse I also want to
say thank you to Cedric Cole who is new
member number six today joined
pakman.com Cedric and Jesse you guys are
great you guys are great people
great
very very strongly feel that see Bishop
Davis's Trump won't really open the
country back up right he's alluding to
it he's alluding to it and oh hold on
Mike Pence is holding up his power and
for anyone who has a vulnerable senior
in your home I love what dr. fowey and
dr. Burke said not long ago and that is
to keep them safe you should just
conduct yourself if you have someone in
your home is as senior with a serious
underlying health condition did this
they're starting to set the table
they're setting the stage for letting it
rip so to speak very very soon
zesty African says what's your take on
policies counter to the Republican bill
why did she add bells and whistles yeah
Tim Poole sent me a couple messages this
morning and said you've got to see this
1400 page thing that Democrats put
together I've not looked at it yet I've
been filming all morning now I'm doing
the stream Oh God
they brought on dr. oz can you imagine
and I I just haven't looked at it yet I
plan to look at it between today and
tomorrow
Ron says it will take months if not
years to retool factories to produce
medical equipment why is this being
discussed as a short-term solution
yeah so I have a segment today that I've
already filmed it'll be published later
where Donald Trump's Donald Trump has
started lying saying GM and Ford are
producing ventilators not only is it a
lie it's impossible GM has said we have
so under so compare Trump says GM is
making ventilators okay GM says we have
finished a plan for how to obtain most
but not all of the parts we would first
need to get to start making ventilators
okay Trump GM is making ventilators GM
we're almost done with a plan to get
some of the parts to at some point
start manufacturing them which will take
some time and at maximum capacity would
be a few thousand a year right
understand the the imbalance there and
what we're hearing from Trump versus
what we're hearing from the people
actually who have to do the work Mauri
pieces David I was a burner and going to
abstain in the general election kovat
will get me to vote Biden thoughts on
virus changing Democratic turnout on
today's broadcast show and it'll be a
YouTube clip I address that specifically
so I'm trying to avoid doing doing
duplicate stuff but I'll have a clip out
about that it within a few hours thanks
also to crystal R who sends a
five-dollar super chat crystal thank you
very much very much appreciate that and
and appreciate your support is dr. oz
talking to pence right now of dealing
with the symptoms of of coronavirus
we're making that clear across the
country as you know and I'm sure the
president will say this when he joins us
in a bit
the president's very optimistic he's
very hopeful that some of these
anecdotal results that we've seen around
the country will prove out to be true
but I want to assure you there's no
barrier to access to chloroquine in this
country we're working to add to that
supply even as we say again we don't
know that chloroquine is something that
everybody should be taking there are
some there are some real problems in
some people with the chloroquine stuff
so it's very risky to be talking about
that Alex Jones says David do you have
any thoughts on afro pessimism none none
whatsoever
been Beussink says our prediction
markets for kovat case is useful I don't
know you know I've not actually seen
let's see predict wise Co vid let's see
I've not seen any of it um okay I'm not
seeing anything there predict it co but
if somebody can tell me a prediction
market where I could look at covent
stuff I would be interested in looking
at it but I'm not seeing anything if
someone super chats me where there are
Co vid related prediction markets I
would check it out Tyler Kozlowski says
Newsom said Elan delivered a thousand
ventilators yet
I don't believe he'll on musk
manufactured them right Elon Musk a
thousand ventilators I think he just
bought them uh let me take a look here I
have an article for us to take a look at
Elon Musk has delivered what Elon Musk
has delivered a thousand ventilators to
help California patients California
received these provided by Elon Musk
heroic effort yet there's no indication
it seems like Elon Musk just procured
these as no factories right we're
working on ventilators even though I
think there will not be a shortage by
the time we can make enough to matter
yeah so I think Elon Musk just bought
those those are not ones that Tesla has
has manufactured okay Jimmy big nuts hey
Jimmy has says here's some coins David
keep it up thanks Jimmy Jackson says
what's your look ideal support package a
thousand a month two thousand a month
one big check
so I'm opting out of opining on this
because I'm just not qualified to say I
know everybody has some hot take I don't
want to contribute to the disinformation
I think we need you know respectable
economists and financial forecasters to
the extent that financial forecasting is
a thing making the decisions and once we
have a package believe me I will analyze
it and comment on it let me say thank
you to Jacob winning winning for a
getting subscription number seven today
at joined pakman.com jessica harper is
new member number eight at join
pakman.com you know it's it's a
remarkable thing shows like ours have
overwhelmingly male audiences this
applies to you know the sam cedars show
the young turks we just it's a
phenomenon that we've identified we have
overwhelmingly male audiences during the
Cova 19 crisis and the streams the
number of female members that have been
signing up has been off the charts and i
don't know if it's just more people or
home and for whatever reason the
audience has drastically equalized where
it has gotten much closer to 55
the male/female we've never seen
anything like this and it's reflected in
the in the membership sign ups also want
to say thanks to Ryan Alston Ryan is new
member number nine today at join
pakman.com I would be interested in a
hypothesis about why the female audience
has increased so drastically during
during kovat 19 I don't have an answer I
don't have an answer
eat okay says thanks for your voice it's
very important thank you for your
support o Karsh vivek says hey david
thoughts on andrew cuomo's conference
today again i have not seen it i've been
producing today's show so that we could
stream this town hall so i've not seen
any any conferences today kelly d says
do you think the chinese government will
be asked to answer about why they waited
so long before telling the world about
what was happening I mean at some point
hopefully right now it's not hugely
relevant to figuring out next steps but
yes I would love to get answers for sure
Tyler and the residents says dr. oz has
many blind followers that listen to his
every word if he puts out good advice it
might be the best way to influence those
people what are your thoughts yes if he
puts out good advice he was repeating
some of the unsubstantiated chloroquine
stuff just a couple days ago so it's a
big if Issac Sosa says I'm not gay but I
would be in a non-sexual bromance with
David oh that's interesting and very
interesting Isaac Alex Jones says are
you always in favor of legalized
abortions I sort of reject the premise
because usually that type of question is
opening the door to starting to talk
about late-term and things that are very
very very rare and so so I sort of
reject the framing of the question I
believe that abortion is a legal medical
procedure like many many others about
which decisions should be made by
medical professionals and the people
involved in the procedure
Ian says bring back morality with
automata yeah I'm actually having a
Google hangout later today with Louis
and a couple other of our elementary and
high school friends and I was thinking I
would pull Louis into a stream soon
maybe like a nighttime stream I mean
Louis isn't doing anything but as you
all know you know Louis's schedule is
very very particular and I might be able
to pull him into a stream soon but you
if you're wondering about this we used
to do a segment called morality with
Motamedi maybe I can even find one as we
wait here where our old producer would
answer moral dilemmas and it was usually
pretty funny morality with Motamedi
because a lot of his takes were very
understated let's see a really old one
okay here's one just for kicks okay
we're just doing this while we wait this
is an old morality with Motamedi episode
we got an ad playing here let me excuse
me
apologies for that right oh we got a
second dad apologies very very much
apologizing here it is time for our
second attempt at morality with Motamedi
louis how would you evaluate the
reaction to your moral judgment brought
forth in the first new section of
morality with Motamedi if that could be
any less clear I think people were
outraged to put it lightly I believe
that they were okay here's today's
morality with Motamedi you have a
situation with limited medical resources
hey by the way how relevant is this
question today what is the ethical way
to decide who to treat first do we treat
politicians or celebrities do we go
youngest to oldest is it based on income
is it based on number of children that
would be left without a parent if the
person who needs medical care were to
die louis i turn it over to you how do
you evaluate in a system of limited
medical resources who do you treat first
I think it's almost easier to work
backwards here and say who will you be
treating who is last on the list ah okay
you know when I envision this scenario
I'm thinking of some dystopic a
post-apocalyptic setting where in which
we now find ourselves or you know that
what I'm talking about here you've seen
in the movies you
books medical supplies are very limited
right and you're faced with this with
this quandary here I randomly picked
this and it is literally what we're
trying to figure out today so I think
that most people would agree with me
that based on age and health this is
what you look at first right so if
someone let's say has a terminal illness
it's known that they have a terminal
illness and regardless of their age or
okay maybe first you would evaluate how
long they have and how much of how
useful they are to you your society your
group whatever utilitarian approach well
I think you have to do that so you would
say okay this this person maybe has a
month to live maybe it doesn't make
sense to use those medical supplies and
resources on this person regardless of
their age usefulness strength intellect
whatever okay Wow and then of course you
have the very old people that are with
you the elderly if if you can use those
resources to save someone who is very
young and has a long life ahead of them
as opposed to someone who is maybe only
has a few years or a decade okay people
don't like the 1.25 X well I'll go back
to normal apology let's say something
like that maybe it makes more sense to
use those resources on the younger
person in other words bye goodbye bye
saving younger people you are sort of
maximizing the number of life years that
you are providing via those services if
you have 10 10 year olds and 10 90 year
olds if you save the 10 90 year olds you
guys I don't think I want to do this
right now because we did this like sort
of as a goof years ago and it's kind of
what we're dealing with now and it's
bumming me out so I'm gonna get away
from that I apologize but I'm gonna get
away from that for now because it's just
it's feeling a little too real I don't
know if anybody else agrees let me say
thanks to Harry Sharma who is new member
number 10 today at join pakman.com thank
you so much Harry I so appreciate your
support I also want to say thank you and
welcome to Lorraine Strickland Lorraine
Strickland is new member number 11 today
at join pakman.com remember that we have
a goal of 25 new members you can save
66% with the coupon code 2020 now if
you're just joining us on you
we are waiting for Donald Trump to come
out for this Fox News a virtual Town
Hall please remember to hit like and
subscribe we've had 25,000 people come
through the stream today and only 690
have liked the stream can you imagine
that it is almost irresponsible or
something I don't know but in any case
like the stream and make sure to hit
that subscribe button because it does a
lot for us there we go 738 the numbers
are now starting to climb 840 Wow we
have almost viral growth of likes 961 I
love it I love it appreciate everybody
who's been who's been participating in
the streams 1k we made it okay
slurp slurp says what software do you
use for overlays and such I'm using
stream labs OBS stream labs OBS and then
I have a little text file so it's a
JavaScript thing where I guess so when
somebody signs up like we have 11 now I
can change it to you know a hundred and
eleven boom and it fills up we'll go
back to 11
I can also make it you know 11 of 11 of
a lot whoa that's not quite so good but
we're at 11 of 25 and then I think I can
also let's see can I change it to like
11 of 25 genius members yeah look at
that
11 of 25 genius members maybe I'll just
put website members maybe that's clearer
11 of 25 website members which might
just make it more obvious what we're
tracking there I like it I like it okay
Alex Jones says explain your opposition
to the public option I'm not opposed to
it it's just not the best thing the
public option would basically just
reduce premiums by 7 to 8 percent
according to the best studies I've seen
that's less than than the yearly
increase so the public option
essentially buys us a year it's just not
nearly enough I'm not opposed to it it's
better than what we have if the options
are what we have or what we have plus
the public option I take the public
option that's it
Tylar Kozlowski says you were right I
found this musk said on Twitter that
China had an oversupply so we bought
1255 fda-approved ResMed Phillips and
Medtronic ventilators on Friday night
and air shipped them to Los Angeles yes
indeed
Allison Jeffrey says I am a long time a
female listener perhaps we're just quiet
I hope it's that rather than females
being less interested in politics love
your show here is Donald Trump walking
out for the start of the townhall let's
listen graceful for your town I need him
to keep it coming and we're about to
bring the president president Trump is
heading over now he'll answer your
questions as well
for the next hour our virtual town hall
continues with the vice president and
now president Trump next okay looks like
they're taking a little break before
they start let's see here other super
chats is it better for Dems to just pass
a bill so less people lose their jobs my
work is falling apart something is gonna
have to be passed soon there's no doubt
about that
crystal says David please look into into
methylene blue I will look into it
I don't have any idea what it is and
methylene blue medication and dye used
to treat meth Oh globin levels greater
than 30% okay I will check it out blue
Roy says are an Arizona man died and
wife in ICU for ingesting an aquarium
cleaner because it contained chloroquine
yep report we discussed it today on the
show clip coming out soon carpe Donnelly
says it's amazing that we had a serious
presidential candidate outline verbatim
how to fund implement and deploy a ubi
that could fundamentally change the game
and politicians just ignore it
categorically it is depressing it is
very very depressing let me say thank
you and welcome to Kara Holt who is new
member number 12 today very much
appreciate that Kara thank you join Kara
by grabbing a membership at join
pakman.com been Beussink says kovat
prediction market google hyper mind
kovat 19 hyper
mind kovat 19 let's take a look here see
what people are kind of putting their
money on so to speak at the end of March
how many cases will have been confirmed
most people say between 500,000 and a
million yeah that's almost certain
certainly going to be the case we are at
400,000 right now with six and a half
days to go I think it will be between
500,000 and a million that seems that
seems correct
I guess there's an entire coronavirus
section case is confirmed how many will
be confirmed in the US over a hundred
thousand that's interesting could be and
that very well may be
Leigha that let's look at that later
because that is very interesting we
don't want to miss the town hall but I'm
gonna check that out Mike Valverde says
how do I catch your full show now that I
have a membership login on our website
click on member content member content
2020 every day we post the full
commercial free show and the Members
Only bonus show they're very very easy
to do let me also say thank you to
Edward Stewart who is new member number
13 today at join pakman.com Edward thank
you very much appreciate it Internet
connoisseur says thank you Pakman for
working and you're sourced info Cassie
winters has subscribed on YouTube Walker
Anderson says what's the reason you
blocked my other account for super
chatting we've never blocked anyone from
super chatting I don't even know that
that's possible we've never done it and
I don't I could not answer but I've
we've not yeah you know people get these
ideas that that things are a lot of
times we have no idea what's going on I
have not blocked anybody from super
chatting internet connoisseur is a new
member Mike Balog says Florida is in
deep [ __ ] and there's no toilet paper
proverbially metaphorically and
literally it sounds like all right let's
get to Trump's Town Hall I'm gonna
refill my water and then be here with
with all of you guys watching myself
rusev is coronavirus Task Force on Bill
Hemmer at the Rose Garden here at the
White House Harris and I'm harris
faulkner in New York the
administration's 15-day plan you saw the
vice president holding that up several
times the plan is to curb the spread of
covin 19 in the United States and it's
set to expire in less than a week from
today now President Trump and his task
force are plotting the way forward for
all the nation in the next hour joining
us to talk about all that President
Trump and still with us
vice president Mike Pence the White
House coronavirus response coordinator
dr. deborah birx and the Surgeon General
dr. Jerome Adams and welcome and thank
you all for being here
unusual circumstances where we you're
trying to communicate with the American
people we're trying to maybe bring the
American people a little closer to you
and get some answers to you mr.
president when was the moment that you
thought we got a move on this well I
think when I started seeing and reading
about China and seeing what was going on
in China
Wuhan specifically it seemed to come
mostly out of there at that area the
province and when I saw that and I saw
the kind of death they were you know
talking about on television on in the
papers and I started reading a lot about
it and really want to had to make a
decision do I stop people from China and
specifically that area but from China to
come into the country and everybody was
against it almost everybody I would say
was just absolutely against it we've
never done it before we never made a
decision like did somebody come to you
with a bit of information and a piece of
data was it a world leader was it a
member of your own Sue's instance no we
had a large group of people right behind
me in the Oval Office and I made it I
consulted with Mike but we made a
decision I made a decision to close off
to China that was weeks early and
honestly I took a lot of heat
sleepy Joe Biden said it's xenophobic I
don't know if he knows what that means
but that's okay he said it's racist what
I did thousands and thousands of more
people probably tens of thousands would
be dead right now if I didn't make that
decision and I must say doctors nobody
wanted to make that decision at the time
it was very very early called it lucky
Cola talent it doesn't matter we made a
great decision I took a lot of heat from
China they weren't happy with it
now they understand it and they've
really you know we're doing just fine
but they were not happy with it we're
bringing it from a lot of people bring
the conversation to present day and the
past day and a half you got a lot of
tension for this a tweet that I think
went out late at night you said the cure
we cannot let the cure be worse than the
problem itself so you start to look at
this 15-day period which will come to us
day 15 is next Monday today arguably day
9 what are you trying to gauge as to how
you can open the country back up yes
when you say I took a lot of heat for
that essentially I really didn't I mean
a lot of people agree with me our
country is not supposed to be you know
it's not it's not built to shut down our
people are full of vim and vigor and
energy they don't want to be locked into
a house or an apartment or some space
they it's not for our country if we're
not we're not built that way and I said
you know I don't want the Cure to be
worse than the problem let's watch the
stock market there's a problem and you
know you can destroy a country this way
by closing it down where it literally
goes from being the most prosperous I
mean we had the best economy in the
history of our country
three weeks ago and then all of a sudden
we're supposed to shut it down and then
we're supposed to pay people not to go
to work we never had that we used to pay
people to go to work when I had but this
is a government order to go ahead and
stay home it's tricky though when you
try and turn the faucet back on drink
New York could be different from this
Utah Louisiana could be different from
Arizona so how do you go about making
that decision
well you have to make the decision look
we lose thousands I brought some numbers
here will as thousands and thousands of
people a year to the flu we're we go
with that turn the country off I mean
every year now when I heard the number
you know we average the flus not
overwhelming the ice thousand people can
you believe that and actually this year
were having a bad flu season but we lose
thousands of people here to the flu we
never turned the country off we lose
much more than that to automobile
accidents we didn't call up the
automobile companies say stop making
cars
remember automobile accidents are not
rising exponentially in the United
States while other countries are seeing
declines because of the changes they've
made honestly the American people have
learned we've all learned together
between the shaking of the hands or the
washing of the hands I used to wash my
hands that I always wash my hands a lot
I never was a big believer in shaking
hands once I've become a politician you
shake hands and you get a little bit
used to it like immediately when I see
you I sort of apologize that I'm not
checking will we exchange the air elbows
which is seems to be things that I never
like to see that actually but yeah but
right now on Capitol Hill you've got
members of the Senate debating a two
trillion dollar bill yeah more than did
you think that it blows away the ability
for us to imagine that they could pass
legislation in excess of two trillion
dollars no who knows what's behind the
curtain there who knows what is stacked
into two trillion dollars how much
concern do you have oh we can't tell if
you can see facing criticism that
President Obama faced and in 2009 we
come out sweetheart deals for certain
companies as Democrats would argue I
cancel the deal list notice that I'm not
gonna sign that deal because Nancy
Pelosi came and he put a lot of things
in the deal that had nothing to do with
the workers that had to do with an
agenda that they've been trying to get
passed for 10 years and I
came in I told Mike I told a lot of
people there's no way I'm signing that
deal I was getting calls from John
Kennedy from Ben Sasse from many many
people Lindsey I was getting calls from
a lot of different people saying this
deal Tom cotton this deal is terrible
what they've done they took it to you
you know we almost had a deal the day
before and it was between Schumer and
Mitch and it was really a good solid you
all of a sudden they start throwing all
of the little green New Deal stuff in
right and the boardrooms what they
understand that Democrats are throwing a
lot of BS in that's unrelated but they
want it to be a slush fund for Stephen
minuchin to give money to companies
Trump likes it's sick on both sides and
it's not good for American Mills they
killed the birds and ruined the real
estate right a lot of problems I mean a
lot of problems and I said I'm not
signing this with two trillion dollars
now they've read hard to avoid some of
those you could argue but we have great
things for not only companies forget the
companies the companies are nothing
other than they are an employer of
thousands and thousands of people and
they pay them very well we want to
protect our workers I want to protect
our workers workers first mm-hmm but you
have to protect companies like Boeing
they had a real bad year let's face it
with the problems and they were in
trouble before this and then all of a
sudden this market down almost the
pointless of throwing these companies
and companies frankly bill that were
solid as like triple-a companies because
of what's happened over the last couple
of weeks they go from triple-a to being
like they could use a hand tough time we
can't do right we can't lose those
companies if we lose those companies
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of jobs millions of jobs the
faster we go back the better it's going
to be we have a pent-up energy that's
gonna be unbelievable we gonna bring it
back fast
I really believe I've got a lot more
questions and I might sit as my
colleague harris faulkner I'll allow her
to rejoin the conversation now Harris do
I have an ear plug here
okay
hello mr. president see you today this
will be a little bit too real eh I
understand you guys are going back and
forth on the economy and employers but
more than 66 percent of people are
employed by small businesses the VP
talked a little bit about this we hear
you dropping big companies names the
question here is this is are you sure up
both as you look forward the question is
a good one and it's pointed you're
talking about Boeing and yet you've got
what two-thirds of American businesses
or small business and you think about
what they're trying to do in terms of
adjusting to this new reality has been
thrown on them what will you do is
hammer gonna soften everything I have to
say that Paris is one of my favorite
people right and I didn't hear a word
she said and I was hoping it wasn't too
devastating in question but she is a
fantastic person I have to say that okay
now that I've said it because I can't
hear Harris but right no the bill is
very much focused on the small business
person it's very much focused on small
companies including restaurants and all
sorts of small companies and what people
don't realize you know you're talking
about these massive we have the greatest
companies of the world you talk you add
them all up and the small businesses are
just about equal in size to these
massive companies of which we have many
also it's it's the engine of our
country's small business this bill is
absolutely aimed at the small business
and the worker and the workers of those
small businesses and the owners the
owners are gonna need help they're gonna
need some loans they're gonna need
things that we're gonna be able to take
care of them because we don't want those
small businesses to go out of business
nor do I want the big businesses to go
out of business when they said mr.
president we gotta shut this down how
hard did you push back I never heard of
such a thing we've had flus where we
lose 36,000 oh that we lose again I
guess the 78,000 people in one year and
they came in and they said to be sir
we're gonna have to close the country I
said what are you talking about well we
have a virus it's coming in and I knew
and I made the early decision with China
just remember guys the flu rises and
falls to a different degree seasonally
we're dealing with something that based
on our actions is growing exponentially
in coronavirus never happened before
you're saying I said are you are you
serious about this we are going to take
this country that's fully employed well
we have 160 million people working and
you tell me we have to close it and
people are gonna go at a business and
they're gonna go bankrupt and they're
not gonna have jobs what are we talking
about here
this don't forget this has never been
done we've had flus before we've had
viruses before so this is something new
and this is why I say we have to I gave
it two weeks and you know I guess by
Monday or Tuesday it's about two weeks
and we'll assess at that time and we'll
give it some more time if we need a
little more time but we have to open
this country when they came to you and
had that conversation with you how long
did it take you to accept that new
reality
I look I accept things I understand
things very quickly I mean I understood
exactly what they were saying
but we can socially distance ourselves
and go to work and you'll have to work a
little bit harder you can clean your
hands five times more than you used to
you don't have to shake hands anymore
with people that might be something good
coming out of this well that didn't work
you petition it's a lot warmer when you
walk into a crowd you shake it a lot of
people's hands you love hotter good I'd
agree with you they love me and I love
them you know but but it is a little bit
colder but so many people are gonna die
King hands for at least a while and and
things will happen but we have to put
the country to work look you're gonna
lose a number of people to the flu right
you're gonna lose more people by putting
a country into a massive recession or
depression the other illness people how
we're gonna have suicides by the
thousands you're gonna have all sorts of
things happen you're gonna have
instability you can't just come in and
say let's close up the United States of
America the biggest the most successful
country in the world by far you know
when I came in when I was elected and
you knew this number China
gonna overtake us in the year 2019
wasn't even close we went way up and
they didn't we've done great they pay us
a fortune in tariffs and everything else
no we paid it their relations you still
don't know how terrible side to trade
deals but with the number one in the
world by far and now number 104 people
walk into the Oval Office say sir we
have to close up the country and the
Saudis I said what do you know that mr.
president must have been a very
difficult thing to accept
look at him er trying to humanize him
and Trump just rattles insanity because
I knew that when you do it as soon as
you do it you're gonna drop I mean
they're talking about 20 or 25 points of
GDP nobody's ever heard of 25 points if
we went down a point that's a big deal
now all of a sudden you're basically
turning off the country I said this has
never been done before what are you
talking about but we understand it you
have hot spots but we've had hot spots
before we've had horrible flus
I mean think of it we averaged 36,000
people
death death I'm not talking about cases
I'm talking about death 36,000 deaths a
year people die 36 from the flu but
we've never closed down the country for
the flu so you say to yourself what is
this all about
now how did you it's never been - how
did you process that third atelic I
wasn't happy about it
and I also knew that I had to do it
because look with Turkey
I give this as an example in Syria I
said sign a deal with the Kurds make
peace there - one he didn't want to he
said he's a man who loves Turkey this is
unrelated relation I said sign a deal he
didn't really want to the Kurds didn't
really want to and it went on you know
the so-called safe zone the recently a
few months ago I said sign the deal do
me a favor sign it they'll get it done
they didn't really want to all of a
sudden they start fighting fighting
fighting fighting and it was vicious and
other countries got involved now I say
let's sign a deal
said okay well sign a deal we needed a
period because I don't think if I would
have not what is he talking about we
would have been unbelievably criticized
for not doing it but it's never been
done before
one more somehow the word got out that
this is the thing we're supposed to be
doing now we've had some really bad
epidemics with with this voice of things
I mean we're going this pandemic but
we've had bad epidemics I'm sure they
could have been called pandemics but we
never did a thing like this before but
it had to do it it's been very painful
we're screwed for our country and very
destabilizing for our country and we
have to go back to work much sooner than
people thought and people can go back to
work and they can also practice good
judgment one last question then we get
back to our viewers here too a month ago
the CDC had an initial test that failed
at that moment late February you said
it's perfect and it wasn't perfect so
what happened asking why stages well was
in late fit as perfect was my
conversation with the head of the
Ukraine that's what I really said is
perfect okay that was another hole
not since a total you know witch hunt
but this one is a much different thing
resigned other administration's not just
the last one they built up a platform
they built up a test but the test was no
good it didn't handle large numbers of
people it was okay for a very small
group but not for a large group so we
have to break it down did the CDC screw
up or did you screw no I we did not
screw at this and funneling CDC screwed
up either they had a test that would
have worked for a small group of people
in other words for a normal problem I
don't think anybody could have
in all fairness to CDC and this is a big
government agency and they're very good
people in there but nobody ever expected
a thing like this nobody would say that
millions and millions of people would
have been tested so what we did is we
broke that egg we broke that system and
we've created a
new system that now we're doing
unbelievably big numbers and it's set
for the future should we ever need it
again we're doing it again thank you for
your time we're gonna bring the others
in as well in a moment thank you for
being patient we will get to you we have
so many Crum our network but from
millions of people all across the
country so your questions in a moment
here as we continue live in the Rose
Garden at the White House with the
president and his task force in
Washington guys were seriously screwed
with this guy no foul Qi first of all
they figured out deborah birx will sort
of do Trump's bidding this we're so the
degree to which we are screwed with this
guy is shocking shocking let me say a
huge thank you to Grand alien for
cheering ten thousand bits on Twitch
thanks to grayton B as well as gold
public blue horseshoe and water girl all
of whom have grabbed twitch
subscriptions we're all trying to deal
with the dystopia together let me say
thank you to a nunzio tech cole who is
new member number fourteen today at join
pakman.com camden margulies is new
member number 15 today annalee klein is
new member number 16 Katelyn Haney hey
Caitlin Caitlin's new member number 17
today Aaron Allen is new member number
18 and really appreciate everybody's
everybody support a quick look at the
Super chats love inspired says is he
freaking serious he's absolutely
deranged yes we are in the dystopia you
know I'm reading the Testaments which is
the sequel to Handmaid's Tale by the by
the incomparable Margaret Atwood and
reading dystopian fiction has changed
because I prefer it when it's only
fiction and it's not only fiction at
this point every day were presented with
the real dystopia in which we are living
Lonny Kratz says I'm glad I no longer
live in the US but my family does and I
am deeply concerned yeah I mean we've
got idiots Jackson says we're all gonna
die Amy Gareth says a hundred and forty
deaths in the last 24 hours
Fox News
shows 14 info minimal says quarantine
life is sloth living like orange cassidy
essential asks are accounts linked
youtube and david pakman.com no all of
these if you're a youtube member it has
nothing to do with being a member on my
website these are all totally different
unrelated unconnected systems so Marie
mcf says where is doctor foul Chee
speechless from Trump's medical
knowledge and the great job he's doing
yeah it did this is the worst that this
format is even worse than the daily
press briefings it's crazy
Tyler solder asks thoughts on 21 million
closed Wireless accounts in CN I don't
know anything about that so I wouldn't
be able to comment MK crisp says my
uncle is currently on a ventilator in
London with kovat Britain's response has
been slow and poor people suffering stay
indoors people I'm really sorry to hear
that and yeah a lot of a lot of a lot of
responses have not been good Bri says I
think the algorithm does not help
promote your audience I'm a woman and
I've subscribed to support you as you
are the best commentator around well we
need to mold the algorithm like a lump
of clay and the best way to do it is if
you're watching on youtube hit like and
hit subscribe because what if if people
watch the stream and they say wow this
is triggering me to like and subscribe
YouTube believes we should promote this
because there's a high like and
subscribe ratio that's why it matters
back to the delusions back to our Fox
News virtual town hall with President
Trump and his coronavirus task force
excited to finally get to be able to
talk one on one with him now we got our
tech problems worked out I want to first
ask you mr. president about the idea of
political division that's going on on
Capitol Hill you're talking about these
bills this phase one two and three of
the stimulus bill like they're gonna fix
so much with the economy and people are
literally fighting like cats I mean what
can you do to bring them together
well I think they're actually coming
together we had a bill that was done the
other night and then all of a sudden
somebody else elected herself in and all
of that we didn't have a we didn't have
anything that was even remotely signed
able but now I hear just from a few
minutes ago that they're doing well and
it's for the workers it's for the people
of the country and I hear they're doing
pretty well so we'll see how it comes
out but it should have been well it's
like I watched Governor Cuomo and he was
very nice we're building him hospitals
we're building on medical centers and he
was complaining about we only think
Trump cares about is whether governors
are being nice to him rather than
whether we're dealing with the crisis
talking about the ventilators but he
should have ordered the ventilators and
he had a choice he had a chance because
right here I just got this out that he
refused to order 15,000 ventilators I'll
show this to bill but take a look at
that bill what does that say here this
says New York Governor Cuomo rejected
buying recommended 16,000 ventilators in
2015 for the pandemic for a pandemic
established death panels and a lotteries
instead yeah he put in death panels to
buy in 2015 16,000 ventilators at a very
low price and he turned it down I'm not
blaming him or anything else sky
shouldn't be running a preschool he's
supposed to be buying his own
ventilators we're gonna help but you
know if you think about ITIF you think
about Governor Cuomo wig building him
for hospitals we're building him for
medical centers we're working very very
hard for the people of New York we're
working along with him and then I watch
him on the show complaining and he had
16,000 ventilators that he could have
had it a great price that he didn't buy
him yeah and I hear you going back and
forth then and Governor Cuomo has talked
in recent days that you regularly talk
and have a good relationship and so we
will follow the news as you're bringing
it to us they're right there in the Rose
Garden I want to get to a viewer because
the people's voice is so huge right now
and all
waise mr. president Jessie submitted a
question from Facebook about the
stimulus checks let's watch and I want
to get your reaction I'm fortunate I can
continue to work
I can telecommute there are people who
are losing jobs they're losing an entire
income for a household and rather than
receive a check I would just like to pay
it forward and have the government
passed mine on to someone else
Wow is that great well you gotta pass
things before anybody can pass their
check to somebody else very much that's
great I wish we had more people like
Joyce I'll tell you but you know it's
gonna be a substantial amount of money
around $3,000 for a family of four and
assuming it all gets done assuming we
can get the Democrats to sign it but
it'll be great but Joyce I think that's
such a nice gesture really I appreciate
it thank you well and you just said
right when you and I began talking a few
minutes ago that you know the juggernaut
might be moving on Capitol Hill to try
to push toward that stimulus bill so
we'll be watching for that you know mr.
president I'm watching the Dow as you
have been talking and formerly the vice
president it's up by more than 1500
points but down a point since Trump
started each day I mean are you keeping
your eye on that is it is it companies
calling you small and large like what
what is your barometer that okay things
are in trouble or things are doing
better well I think the Dow was helped
by the fact that they you know there
were theories that we're going to stay
out for four or five months and you
can't do that as they couldn't you
destroy our country if you did a thing
like that and we're gonna be opening
relatively soon and we are our time
comes up a better question would be mr.
president the Dow immediately dropped
when you started speaking today why do
you think that is it open very soon I
think that was a big reason it's gone up
I also think that the fact that the
Senate and the house side we seem to be
getting along as much as you can get
along we seem to be getting along now on
a on a bill I think that maybe had even
less of an impact
the fact that we're opening up this
incredible country because we have to do
that I'd love to have it open by Easter
okay I would love to have it open by you
sir I will I will tell you that right
now I would love to have that it's such
an important day for other reasons but
I'll make it an important day for this
too I would love to have the country
opened up and just raring to go
by Easter least that's not tomorrow well
so we will watch and see what happens
I'm gonna toss it back to my cohort bill
Thank You Harris that would be a great
American resurrection two and a half
Plus weeks from this and it will lead to
hundreds of thousands of questions on
the medical front here I want to go to
Allison from Indiana appropriately so
mr. vice president who has a question by
way of facebook about possible mutation
watch my question is this if you were to
get the corona virus can it mutate and
can you get it again mm-hmm dr. Burks so
that's a great question and a very smart
question because it's an RNA virus it
can mutate and it constantly mutates but
what has been pretty good about the
corona viruses in general is they keep
their structural pieces very similar
what do I mean by that there's certain
the outer coat the envelope and the
inside part of the virus has stayed very
constant it's even very similar to SARS
which we haven't seen since 2003 and so
we what has been picked for sites both
for the vaccine and for monoclonal
antibodies are very much those constant
sites and we believe that anybody who
becomes positive and makes effective
antibody because there are some people
who can't make as good of antibody as
others but if you make effective
antibody you shouldn't get reinfected
the way it was described to me and
correct the medical positioning of this
question but the virus is trying to
figure out a way to survive and that's
where it moves around and it mutates now
in Singapore there is a headline earlier
today suggesting a possible second wave
in that island
how do you how do you gauge that we're
in Singapore they took the president's
guidelines and they executed them very
early because they could see China next
door yeah before the presidency so very
few people became infected in Singapore
because so few people have been infected
you don't have what they call herd
immunity and so until we get through
this current pandemic this if it has
seasonality which we hope and believe it
could if it gets through this current
season it will be in everybody's best
interest guys it's really sad that Bao
she's gone after making like two
critical comments about Trump and now
Burks is here and she's just completely
fallen in line with Trump health care
providers can get get a shot potentially
that will protect them we would call it
pre exposure prophylaxis all of those
things are being worked on to prepare us
for the next season we're so we're
focused today on what we need today and
to get through this current epidemic and
then we're also getting prepared in case
it comes back in the fall or in case it
comes back in the fall of 2021 when we'd
have it back I'm gonna bring the Surgeon
General in this and to both of you I've
been listening to you very carefully for
weeks now and what you said is we want
to be the model of South Korea well
South Korea has flattened the curve to
borrow a phrase and their death rate is
about 1.2 percent this morning here in
the US our death rate was right around
that same mark 1.3 percent - the Surgeon
General what does that tell you or how
much do you consider the death rate here
at home when we try and make decisions
for ourselves well thank you for that
bill I think there are a couple of
important things for the American people
to remember the first one answer the
book when you look at the data here in
the United States of all the people who
we've tested so far only about 90
percent of those well ninety percent of
those folks do not have the coronavirus
Arella test negative so most people even
when they have cold and flu symptoms do
not have coronavirus number one number
two 98 99 percent of people are
recovering so
people need to understand yes this was
not what was asked get coronavirus in
many communities across America but that
most of them will recover that that's
very important for people to understand
and beyond that we're trying to help
people understand the importance of
stopping the spread and the president
when he nine days ago listened to his
health his health providers his health
health consultants he said what do we
need to do right now and we said we need
to lean into this next two weeks to stop
the spread and then we need to reassess
and one thing I can tell you for certain
is that I've been on the task force for
three weeks and the president listens to
Tony Falchi he listens to dr. Burks he
listens one eye or dr. Carson or dr.
Hahn or dr. Redfield speak up and he
also listens to the governor's and so we
will assess at the end of the 14 days
and we'll figure out the most
appropriate thing to do and based on my
experience in the task force so far the
president will make an appropriate
decision based on all the data thank you
for that answer is everything cool with
you and dr. Falchi he was not there he
wasn't there last night for the briefing
he's not here today as he has other your
relationships good I think it's been
very good you would have heard about it
we have every time he does he's not in a
meeting and sometimes other people do
they said why isn't dr. Brooks at a
meeting is there a problem
and I said Debra could you please come
to the meeting do you mind because no
they they you know I respect all of
these people these are great people
these are Christ is extraordinary to
borrow it's Tony's extruder I get along
with all of them but if there's you know
they have other things to do and
yesterday we weren't really talking
about what he's an expert on we were
talking about other things a lot of
other things and you know they I don't
think they should be at every so he's
come you're good that's the point yeah
what five dr. Burks early on you said it
was a massive amount of testing in South
Korea ninety six percent to the surgeon
general's what 96 percent came back
negative I think that's an important
point to convey again to the American
people how so know what from Maryland
has a question now his question is about
health care workers on the front lines
this pandemic now my mother is a nurse
she works in the healthcare field what
do you and your team plan to do to help
health care workers that are putting
themselves at risk every single day as a
result of the corona virus you know
weird question dr. Burks you want to
yeah that's I love that question because
my mother's a nurse she's 91 now so
she's not practicing but I think we have
to remember in majority of hospitals and
a majority of places it is the nurse
that are the frontlines they're the ones
working every moment with the patients
to ensure that they do well they're the
ones at the bedside they're the ones
providing comfort they're the ones
providing the medical interventions and
they are our first priority is why we've
worked so hard to get the protective
personal protective equipment out there
but I think what we didn't often talk
about is we're really with the changing
guidelines for testing that is gonna
free up all of that personal protective
devices that were being utilized for
testing back into the hospitals and the
clinics for our nurses and doctors and
that's gonna make millions of more masks
and PPE as we call it available to the
hospital workers who need it the most
because now people can self test and
bill can I jump in on that really
quickly I want people to know that I'm a
still practicing anesthesiologist at
Walter Reed the Vice President and I we
first met during Ebola and I went into
the hospital I put on PPE I know how
scary it is even when you have the
proper equipment to deal with an
infectious disease and I'm getting text
phone calls messages from people all
across the country and I want health
care workers of America to know we are
fighting for you each and every day to
make sure you get what you need from the
stockpile to make sure you get what you
need from manufacturers across America
to make sure you're getting decreased
demand which is why we put out our new
guidelines on elective surgeries because
it's not just about increasing the
supply we aren't going to supply our way
out of this problem as important as
supply is correct need to also lower
demand by decreasing unnecessary usage
of PP
in a game-changer that just came out
just this week was the new FDA self
swabs and the vice president and the
president have talked about that that
will utilize less PPE so we're working
on making sure supply gets where it
needs to and FEMA is doing a great job
without lowering to me how can someone
watching this right now acquire itself
down or feel good at all right now the
FDA is making that more available we've
seen testing increase in real numbers
when you look at last week from Monday
to Friday the amount of testing
increased tenfold so we're seeing
testing increase that the concern is it
is actually using up more PPE which is
why we want to prioritize testing for
the people who are most in need the
healthcare workers and the people who
are vulnerable and why we're pushing the
FDA has lowered barriers like none other
to make sure we can get these new
testing modalities available they use
less PPE and do more tests thank you for
that back to Harris now with another
question
Harris all right actually you know what
I want to stay on this home testing kit
topic for just a second with dr. Burks
you know the home tests whose is there a
place where people check a box and say
I'm positive or not how are you going to
keep up with people who test themselves
and you need that information dr. Burks
to know where the clusters are well the
testers great so it's not a home test
right soft test is incredibly dumb
question the individual can drive up
receive the items because again we still
want to just test people with fever and
symptoms that are really need to be
tested they can't believe this the front
of their nose put it in the container
and the person can collect it with
gloves gloves alone with the biohazard
bag and get it in I just want to speak
to the Americans for just a second
though we have to ensure that we still
are testing even though probably by
today we will have done more tests than
South Korea did in eight weeks our
population is much bigger though in the
last eight days we've done more testing
than South Korea but we did that because
we transform the testing process as the
president's vote
- but we don't want people who are just
worried to go get tested if you don't
have a persistent fever if you don't
have a coffee if you're not in the risk
group if you're not a nurse or doctor we
really want the testing and the drive
through testing and the testing that is
provided in the cities to be very much
still focused on the people who need it
because there's only so much even those
high throughput machines are doing
they're doing about 50 60 70 thousand
tests a day now they could get
potentially to a hundred and fifty
thousand a day but we want to make sure
we're testing in the areas that really
have the problems and go right ahead
yeah thanks Harris you know the American
people are asking all the time the
president I hear it all the time and see
it it's what I think they do to make it
what the f are you doing and in addition
to the 15 days to slow the spread the
American people could take dr. Burke's
advice it's that old proverb that it's
not the healthy who need a doctor but
the sick and one of the ways that you
can help is by recognizing we want to
focus testing on people that have
symptoms although according to the tests
now as the Surgeon General said ninety
percent of the people that have been
tested for the corona virus don't have
it okay that that number we tested more
than three hundred and twenty thousand
people and and that's an encouraging
number but for any American just me the
people are worried may be concerned but
not be symptomatic one of the ways you
can make sure the testings available for
people that have symptoms and just as
importantly for our health care workers
that we want to make sure have all the
protective equipment that they need you
can you can recognize that if you don't
have symptoms don't do a test
remember Rand Paul had no symptoms got
tested and he has it he went to the gym
again we took something that was broken
and we made it the model and I didn't
even know I just heard the number for
the first time from Deborah that in
a short period of time we've done more
testing than South Korean you're not
gonna read that in the newspapers
because they don't like to write things
like that but per capita it's irrelevant
I'd love you to say that one more time
because that that's a big number
we've done more than South Korea in a
short period of time we're doing more
now than South Korea by Allah what was
that number so we're believing that
they're probably around two thousand
nine twenty nine hundred two thousand
twenty nine thousand two hundred and now
we're our way over three hundred
thousand but we we achieved that over
the last seven to eight days we have to
do more we understand we're going up
proportionately we're going up very very
rapidly every day what was our negative
test rate at the moment it's greater is
it higher so I really I'm glad you asked
because this gets into where is the
virus now and where is it expanding and
so across the country our test rates are
still way under 10 percent except for
one place New York City metro New York
New Jersey close to New York City those
rates are coming in in the 28 percent
range right now New York the case attack
rate what we're talking about the number
of people who are getting infected is
four to five times any other place and
the khawarij is that density popular I
think part of it is density part of is
the spread that may have happened on
metal surfaces like in the subway and
people that were in the subway part of
it may be a large number of people came
back after Christmas from Asia that
didn't get caught up in the closure you
blame the governor for that and part of
it could be the Europeans who have come
back subsequently and there's I mean
obviously it's a big area of world trade
and global transit so I think the virus
probably was quietly expanding because
until it gets into an older population
you don't really see it in the fold you
thank you for that and we'll get to all
of you again in a moment here gonna get
a quick break here more of your
questions from across America here man
every segment is just worse and worse
and worse it's it's just not getting any
better way how can you possibly be
optimistic when this is what these these
are the people that are
leading it's it's stunning stunning let
me say a couple thank-yous Christopher
he'll stay is new member number nineteen
on my website join pakman.com Rolly
Michonne is new member number 20 at join
pakman.com and Mike sous-sous key I hope
that's with the right pronunciation is
new member number 21 remember if you're
joining us on YouTube we are in the
middle of a Trump FoxNews townhall this
apparently instead of today the daily
press briefings that we have been
getting remember if you are watching on
YouTube please consider hitting the like
button and subscribing to my channel we
have surpassed eight hundred and
eighteen thousand subscribers and are
well on our way to eight hundred and
nineteen thousand everybody who likes
and subscribes really is helping us out
significantly and I appreciate that info
minimal says Trump doing wisecracks and
smirking says that via super Chad yeah
it's very bad Lika says watch Cuomo's
press are very dramatic Ryan nawicki
says if someone compares to the flu I
refer them to the metric used to measure
how contagious the disease is known as
reproduction rate keep it up David so
there's two differences that are really
important between the flu it there's
really three between the flu and
coronavirus number one the flu has a
seasonality that does vary each year
there are worse flus and less bad flus
but it's not a situation where it's
growing exponentially and we have to get
it under control
difference number one difference number
two corona virus appears to be
significantly more contagious lately it
appears as though the r4 corona virus
the initial range was one point five to
four point five it seems like they've
narrowed that to somewhere around 2.2 or
2.4 more than the flu less than measles
measles is so contagious I think the are
the contagion rate for measles can be 14
16 18 where someone can get in an
elevator with measles get off you later
get on on a different floor and you
could conceivably get measles and it's
that contagious we're not dealing with
that but we're dealing with something
more
contagious than the flu and then even in
the best case if we have in in this
particular situation a death rate of 0.7
it could be 0.8 it could be one one
point to one point somewhere in there
the flu is 0.15 so we have a
significantly worse death rate so
comparing it to the flu is as wrong as
it is as it is irresponsible quite
frankly let me say thank you to Chad
Lovelace Chad Lovelace is new member
number 22 today at join pakman.com
thanks Chad let's see Shelly Webb says
David I'm trying to join and having
problems with your website a lot of
people are joining so I think the
website is fortunately working well
right now colleague and Kraft says Cuomo
didn't buy ventilators in 2015 really
this is all they've got to pass the
blame
JJ Duff says Fox death number is missing
New York numbers coincidence yeah I
don't have let's take a look I do have
the numbers here the latest numbers if i
refresh today we're looking at plus 69
and yes indeed that data is not what Fox
News has on screen who knows why I think
we can guess we can kill the virus and
give a lot of people hope about getting
back to their regular lives
you said something 20 minutes ago that
I'm sure a lot of people were pretty
keen on you you said that we would I'm
paraphrasing now you would like to be
back to normal by Easter Sunday
yes that's 19 days from now okay is that
true is that possible or is it possible
why isn't it I mean we've never closed
the country before we've had some pretty
bad flus and we've had some pretty bad
viruses and I think it's absolutely
possible now people are going to have to
practice all of the social distancing
and don't shake hands and wash your
hands and all of the things that we're
doing now but we have to get our country
back to work our country wants to be
back at work
that was not a controversial thing I
said the other day our country wants to
go back to work and and again the cure
it's it's like this cures is worse than
the problem again people
many people in my opinion more people
are going to die if we allow this to
continue we have to go back to work our
people want to go back to work what you
have said consistently as the first
order of business is to kill the virus
so so when you look at the data from
around the world across our country how
do you determine that 19 days from now
it might be safe because there are
millions of people watching this it may
have their family fortune on the line
well they have their family fortune on
the line the other way too they're going
to lose their jobs maybe never to get
them back they're gonna lose their
businesses never to get them back we
want to start up as soon as we can
because we're gonna have a very quick
comeback if we do that if we delay this
thing out you're gonna lose more people
than you're losing with the with the
situation as we know it so I think it's
very important for our country to go
back and I've had many many people you
know when you said it was a little bit
controversial and not to most people
most people think I'm right about it now
whether we're locked in a room or
whether we're in our office and
practicing all of the things that we're
supposed to be practicing staying away
from each other you know etc it's not
shaking hands washing your hands all the
time but our country has to get back to
work otherwise otherwise it's going to
be very hard to start it up again we
can't lose the advantage that we have
what we're trying to figure out in this
whole the scenario here is how deadly
the virus is and so far it is highly
contagious but not very deadly we can
agree on that based on the data correct
yes so when you take the answer of
Easter Sunday do you see that as
realistic do you see that as possible so
my job and I think what's really
important is a lot of what we've done is
we've tackled this epidemic the way
people said we should have tackled flu
in 1918 and they compared Saint Louis
who took this kind of approach to
Philadelphia what we're trying to do now
is use 21st century solutions and trying
to get data
to the most granular level so we
understand what's happening at the area
of the spread so even today there are
counties throughout the United States
that don't have their first case so our
job is to make sure they never have
their first case and ensure that our
efforts are focused on where the virus
is expanding that can be done today
because we have that level of
granularity so that's what the president
has asked us to put together to use
these two weeks to get all the data from
around the country and all the data from
around the globe and really understand
what's working and it's really important
that the Americans know I know the vice
president covered this very clearly in
the first hour but every American needs
to continue the president's guidelines
for these next these next six days or
seven days we have to have them
following those guys I see the Surgeon
General shaking you said an agreement to
excuse me just one second you can't
compare this to 1918 we're close to 100
million people died that was a flu which
little different but that was a flu
where if you got it you had a 50-50
chance are very close of dying
I think we're substantially under 1%
because the people that the 1918 flu had
a 50% death rate it can anyone fact
check that that does not sound right in
that and we're still a little bit above
1% when you add all of the people the
millions of people that have it that get
better
we're substantially less than 1% and
when they came to my office don't forget
they were saying 3% for I'm seeing 2.5
percent difference no we have to put our
country back to work we have a few
minutes left
and I want to bring in our panel of
experts to dr. Mehmet Oz is with us dr.
marcoh you know dr. Niccole Safire well
we give you guys around 2 questions
quickly here with dr. oz why don't we
start with dr. Siegel this time around
go ahead mark
mr. president with the deaths going over
600 today I want to say that fear the
fear that's coming out of this disturbs
me the most and fear divides you need
unification and unified leadership to
fight the fear so I really encourage to
see you reaching out the governor's
Governor Cuomo governor Newsom making
making liaisons that weren't there
before do you think that that kind of
movement where you're the leader and
other people work with you
beautiful classless to isolate the virus
and the epicenters where they are two
separate put the question in the trash
this is a trash question there by squash
the virus I do I think dr. it's a very
good thing and governor Newsom and I
have been getting along really great
we're sending the ship the great
hospital ship as you know and we are
doing very well with I think almost all
of the governors for the most part it
really has become something it's it's
we're dealing almost every day we're
speaking to each other whether it's
conference calls usually we'll have 50
governors of the call at the same time
no I think we're doing very well but you
know it's a two-way street they have to
treat us well also they can't say oh gee
we should get this we should get that
we're doing a great job like in New York
where we're building as I said for
hospitals for minute we're literally
building hospitals and medical centers
and then I hear that you know there's a
problem with ventilators well we sent
them ventilators and they could have had
15 or 16 thousand all they had to do is
order them two years ago but they
decided not to do it they can't blame us
for that dr. oz is up next go ahead
doctor let's see what he has a print
President Trump a good surgeon knows
after the surgery when his patient give
me this charge and these 15 days you
like a big operation on America but a
great surgeon knows when there's a
complication after discharge so if we
can meet the goal of fixing America and
getting it back at his feet by Easter I
love to know exactly how you know that
is safe from medical perspective what's
gonna indicate that we might have to
pull back a tiny bit in case we have a
relapse well I think doctor a thing like
that could happen but I really believe
that we can do much of what we're doing
and we can do it from a work environment
instead of a and about you would never
be tolerating these [ __ ] questions
right the business
is gone the business is gone and
everybody's suffering depression you
know better than anybody about
depression I've watched where you talk
about depression and that causes death
and it causes a lot of problems and
there's a nas also promote pseudoscience
depression treatment apartment or house
and in the meantime their restaurants
close their businesses closed they want
to be saving their business and I
believe very strongly
you're gonna lose far more people by
going that way than you are if we kept
this thing going I could keep them at I
mean I'm sure that we have doctors that
would say let's keep it closed for two
years okay let's close it up for two
years now we got to get it open or
people want it open and that's the way
this country was built dr. Nicole
Sapphire now doctor go ahead with your
question thank you and president Trump I
do believe as a nation that we are
beholden to you for your decisive swish
swift action in the beginning with the
program I do think that we would have
been in a much different worse situation
had that not happened however we still
did have a lag in the testing which of
course did not have anything to do with
you but my question is for dr. Burks
and the task force as we still see
across the nation that some people are
not able to get tests I have colleagues
that still can't test some of their
patients is there a plan to fast-track
or even parallel track wrap it Eliza
serological testing to try and get this
out there so that we can mobilize more
PPE and more hospital beds by doing more
testing and being able to isolate those
people quickly yeah that's a very good
question so right now the tests that we
have are all based on the RNA of the
virus and so we're utilizing the
platforms and thank goodness were
utilizing the platforms that were
developed really to work and support
hiv-positive clients so this is they're
they're machines that have been used to
detect their viral load for the last
more than a decade in the United States
those machines right now are being
utilized for this test in a
high-throughput way we've asked
developers to work on a point-of-care
fingerprint test that could be used for
antibody and antigen
but the antibody tests well they tell
you if you have been infected even if we
can get IgM it will be part of the early
and probably recovery phase and then
we're working with companies to work on
getting RNA tests at our point of care
so these are really critical tests that
people are working on right now but in
the meantime we're using what we have
today to ensure that we can get more
testing done and I just want to say I
want to thank the American people and
physicians but let us prioritize
remember we didn't have this platform
until eight days ago we've done all of
these diagnoses for inpatients primarily
so that they can get on the appropriate
therapy and we prioritize our testing to
hospital patients we will over the next
few weeks be able to make more tests
available to the actual American public
with symptoms and to the doctor's
offices as you've requested and Nicole
it's important to remember we've done
more tests in eight days then South
Korea is done in eight weeks and our
tests are better they're highly
sophisticated and frankly I took one
it's not the most pleasant thing in the
world I will tell you that we're gonna
have a much simpler test very soon but
we have a really good test and we've
done more in eight days nobody know that
I just heard this number a few minutes
ago I learned it from being on your show
actually I think the way you express it
was up the nasal passage all of you
stand by we've got a few more moments
left here but as our virtual Town Hall
continues to all the doctors Nicole
Sapphire Manette Oz and Mark Siegel
we very much rely on you in a day to day
basis that's right there being a part of
this today quick commercial break back
to the Rose Garden in a moment as our
town hall what'm I mean this this is
this is just an embarrassment it's a
complete and total embarrassment that I
mean these are the doctors asking
questions this is you know foul she's
gone the Surgeon General and dr. Burke's
have fallen in line they're just
brown-nosing Trump it's it's really sick
let me thank a few other people Joseph
King is new member number 23 today at
join pakman.com Joseph thank you I
appreciate your support
Edward mill Heusen is new member number
24 today very much appreciated and we
are
we are very very close to our goal of 25
new members let me say thank you to some
folks on Twitch cash Lascaux has
subscribed with twitch Prime I also want
to say thank you to
she's a lion dog for cheering two
hundred bits very much appreciated we're
getting down to the last few minutes
here of the Trump Fox News Town Hall if
you're watching on YouTube please
remember to hit that like button and
also hit the subscribe button very much
appreciate everybody who's been
supportive of the streams Tony rice says
Trump is going to get us all killed
that's the feeling from a lot of people
JJ Delaney says watching from Ireland
love your show
do they understand that risk is not only
to the US but everyone you are connected
to and that is everyone in the world you
know I don't pretend to have any idea
what they do or don't understand at this
point Jay HWH says US has only ten times
the cases as Austria but 20 times the
death James justice says his question do
you think being cool and epic is working
yeah the questions from those three
doctors were just an absolute and
complete joke love inspired says they
definitely got rid of foul Qi no
coincidence Charlie says could we be in
worse hands my goodness
it's it's a tragedy it's really a
tragedy that this is what's going on and
our only hope really our only hope is
that we that governors act responsibly
and you know now Trump clearly now is
thinking about around April 12th lifting
the bans or the guidelines and saying
let it rip and I just don't know that
that's really going to be really going
to be enough time Aaron Russell has just
subscribed at join pakman.com and his
new member number 25 today number 25 at
join pakman.com thanks Aaron very much
appreciate it also want to say thanks to
green apples green apples has subscribed
with twitch Prime and one other just one
last reminder tomorrow night 8 p.m.
Eastern the david pack
show viewer chess tournament everybody's
welcome we'll be doing it on li chess
org
I'm the 2019 champion here's my trophy
whoever wins tomorrow night will get
their own trophy we may even make it a
bigger trophy we're looking very
seriously at an even bigger trophy 8
p.m. tomorrow night I'll be streaming as
I play open to everybody absolutely
everybody if you're stuck at home and
maybe chess isn't your favorite but
you're looking for something to do come
participate I look forward to playing
and look forward to getting crushed
certainly by by some of the people in
our audience but that's ok that's ok
porthole says notice the number of
ambulance sirens you know I didn't
notice I I keep hearing Birds during the
during the pressing this uh townhall but
I've not been hearing the sirens back
here in the Rose Garden Bill Hemmer
along with my colleague harris faulkner
have about 90 seconds left and just with
the panel here the president the vice
president dr. Burks and the Surgeon
General thank you again for your time I
see this as a public service but also as
a way to try and figure out what the
facts are and that's the reason we
cannot helping figure it you were just
saying again mr. vice president during
the commercial the way you can achieve
your objective is how well the president
made how our points today that we we
want to open up the country as soon as
we can but the key is the more Americans
and tens of millions are bill more
Americans are put into practice the
president's coronavirus guidelines 53
those office because it's hard to see
the sooner we'll be tens of millions in
a country of 340 million are doing it
it's not enough
Oh hygiene it's it's if you if you're
sick stay home if someone in your house
has the virus stay home but it's also
avoiding groups of more than 10 avoiding
unnecessary travel don't eat in
restaurants during this period of time
use the drive-through these are all the
principles that drive American can do
now there are going to be Americans that
that have different guidance from their
state and local officials that are more
stringent we defer to that we respect
that but the more Americans to do this
the sooner that will be able as the
president said to get back to we have to
be a patient nation if you're
I asked them to do that as you well know
mr. president thank you for your time
and I'll see a bit later on bill hemmer
reports at 3 o'clock Eastern Time into
mr. vice president Mike Pence thank you
dr. Burks terrific work beginner if
you're coming up with that is it from
here at the White House and Harris I
will see you back in New York very soon
I hope the last two hours held some
value for a lot of review they did they
confirmed that we do have completely and
totally incompetent people running the
show and it will be merely by chance if
we can avoid a historically high a death
rate alright guys that does it for me
today I've got to get back to all of my
normal work appreciate everybody who
joined me we'll see you at the next
Trump coronavirus press conference and
also 8:00 p.m. Eastern tomorrow
Wednesday night for the David Pakman
show
viewer chess tournament I'll see you
then Thanks